from Amy Curtis on Twitter that I saw it
said here's why the government is going
to bail out sbv but won't send disaster
Aid to Ohio and you can see an image
showing California as very blue well you
can't really see it because the way it's
cropped on screen there you go and then
you have this image which is Ohio being
like all red and East Palestine being
you know over here in the Eastern Ohio
so a lot of this does absolutely feel
like a combination of elitism and
partisanship the fact that Joe Biden got
up at nine in the morning first thing
and said your money is safe but when a
train exploded spraying toxic chemicals
they they burn and toxic chemicals are
everywhere it's getting in the water
fish are dying the governor says a plume
of chemicals is Flowing down the river
into West Virginia nowhere to be found
it tells you who Butters their bread who
they're serving and who they're
concerned about of course when I look at
things like this and then we had that
Jane Fonda thing do you guys see the
Jane Fonda thing last week Hanoi Jane
talking she said on The View
that she was asked we have to fight for
pro you know for pro-choice whatever and
then Joy Maher was like well short of
protesting and voting what do we do and
she said murder and then someone was
like wait wait what are you saying she
goes murder and they went huh no she's
joking
so the way I see it is all signs are
indicative of systemic collapse whether
the bond market is correct or not in the
previous segment that it's going to
collapse whether the banking thing two
of the biggest collapse in history
happening back to back
and they they're they're seeming like
ones in California one's in New York are
they are they related all I got to tell
you is hyperpolarization hyperinflation
maybe not hyperinflation but the
inflation's ridiculously high now
banking collapses and people on TV
saying psychotic extremist things
how is is Drew you're the expert I guess
or you're the one selling a product do
you think we're on the verge of some
kind of major collapse and should people
I don't want to say be worried but
should they be prepared I think a
recession is likely I don't think a
banking collapse is coming but what
about I mean beyond that I mean when
you're looking at the weaponization of
government when you're looking at people
on TV calling for murder whether to joke
or not we're seeing violence in the
streets we're seeing 150 far leftists
storm a government facility in Georgia
and burn it up then you've got the
January 6th stuff where they're saying
the FBI was destroying evidence it
doesn't feel like this system whether
it's Financial or political exists
anymore it seems more like a smoldering
pit well we track 50 we call them
threats or trigger events that could
lead to a collapse but you're only
talking about one of them and that's you
know something like a financial collapse
or something that really triggers a
civil war if there's a banking collapse
that doesn't mean there's loss of Law
and Order but if people start doing
civil unrest and law enforcement goes
then you've got a class perhaps where
you worry about the things we worry
about which is people going out looting
stealing killing and it's not safe to
live here I mean that's just one of 50
events we have we have more things to
worry about than that I think that are
more likely to get us what like what
what do we got like avian flu is the one
that I'm very concerned about right now
our electric grid is probably my number
two biggest concern the fragility
electric I think that's likely to kill
us off before uh you know collapse from
a banking collapse I've got a bunch of
stuff on the bird flu let's talk about
the electric grid first what what about
the grid has you worried it's been
vulnerable and we've known about it for
decades and the government has done
nothing to fix it it's vulnerable not
just from the physical you know
terrorist attacks you've heard about in
recent months it's vulnerable from
natural causes solar flares
electromagnetic pulse from a solar flare
can take down the Grid it's done it
before the reason why I said we'll talk
about this one first is because you've
heard the stories that are going around
where extremists are attacking
substations it's not the first time they
did an attack on the Metcalf grid you
know a decade almost to go and we knew
about it it was a professional kind of a
test run this is well done look up the
Metcalf attack on the grid it was done
years ago we investigated it was a
professional group that did it it was
like a dress rehearsal I don't know if
Russia or China or who was behind it but
they did a professional years ago in
2013. this is old stuff just like the
the threat of EMP we've known about it
for decades check this out let me read
this on the morning of April 16 2013 a
team of gunmen using rifles opened find
the Metcalf transmission substation
severely damaging 17 Transformers and
and they said it was sophisticated and
what was the reason for them doing it it
was it does a test to see if they could
take it down and the thing is you don't
have to take down you know there's
there's thousands of these stations but
there's critical nodes and if you take
down you know 10 or 12 critical nodes
you can take the whole grid down and the
worst thing is without getting in too
much details you need to watch a
documentary grid down power up EX
explains this a hundred times better
than what I'm going to do in the next 30
seconds but you do a coordinated attack
on the grid it could be a Cyber attack
it could be solar first if there's a
surge in the grid it destroys these
Transformers these big giant devices and
it takes you months to replace a few of
them if a lot of them are destroyed the
electric grid is down for a year under
good conditions or more and we've known
about this and there's five different
ways this could happen Cyber attack
physical attack solar flares
electromagnetic pulse I'm forgetting the
fifth again watch this documentary grid
down power up our grid is highly
vulnerable it's our Achilles heel if
North Korea wants to destroy the United
States they can do it they got an ICBM
that can reach here they do not need a
lot of nuclear weapons they don't need
accuracy at all well one or two high in
the atmosphere over the US and you
destroy our Electric System the
electromagnetic both destroys our system
for over a year for the whole country
for the whole country for most United
States I don't North Korea has weapons
that can do that Yep they're low Yale
see their nuclear weapons have all kinds
of effects thermal radiation Alpha
radiation beta they're optimized to do
maximum EMP yield the Russians work with
them to do that and this has been
published open source it was
Intelligence agencies but they published
open source saying that the Russians
helped North Korea develop their nuclear
weapons for maximum EMP effect because
North Korea is never going to build you
know a first strike capability on our
huge nuclear system but they only need
one or two inaccurate high in the
atmosphere explosions over the U.S and
at greatest down for over a year and in
that time according to a congressional
study you know led by a former CIA
director a former Navy Admiral their
estimate was that when this happens you
could lose 90 percent of the US
population there's no economic
production there's no gasoline there is
no Municipal Water Systems you'll have
no water in this house we will no you
won't yeah we will you're on the
municipal Waters no we're not okay you
may yes
in the city here we are not no are you
kidding 90 of Americans are in cities or
suburbs they'll have no municipation
every water system
either from starving to death or from
people going out stealing for food every
everybody who comes here they're like I
had to drive up a strange winding
Mountain Road to get here we're elevated
several hundred feet like we're up a
mountain and we have well water and two
local water sources now for the new
place we're setting up we actually have
a we have a ton of backup power and here
we have we have miniature solar here so
we have this big massive battery and
then we have a bunch of really small
batteries that are portable and then
they have solar panels that you actually
have to physically lay out and position
properly not easy to do at the other uh
the new property we're setting up we
have installed professional solar with a
ridiculous amount of backup batteries
so the amount of power generated from
the Sun exceeds the amount that the bat
uh the uh the pot the batteries drain so
as long as you're operating through the
day only at night does it power down but
then it immediately goes back to full as
soon as the sun comes up not perfect
absolutely not perfect I'd probably be
comfortable if I use one of the streams
to create a water wheel power generator
of some Source or just a bike some kind
of way to get power because you you're
half correct we wouldn't lose water
because we're not a municipal water but
we need electricity for our pump so
otherwise we're manually pumping water
but worst case scenarios we do what they
did in the olden days and we either
carry bales of water up the hill which
we can do or we we build a pump or dig a
well or something
I think uh
the me and the people here we've been
reading so much about this stuff
non-stop for the past three or four
years five years heck 10 years that uh
look we've been saying on the show get
chickens get get some small goats some
uh what the the Nigerian dwarf goats or
whatever get something get away from the
cities I've had a lot of people message
saying they moved out of the city they
got they're they're on well water
they're more sustainable they've got
chickens hey I'll tell you what
if these people who are attacking the
power substations succeed because we've
been seeing reports of it all over the
country or North Korea fires an EMP what
you're saying makes the most sense you
want to win a war you don't want you
don't need to wipe a city out with
massive destructive force that's a waste
of energy that's that's that's that's
that's a lack of strategy One EMP
disables your opponent and then you've
won so what will the people in the
cities do yeah right they're gonna have
no water how many days until they start
eating each other and drinking each
other's blood
and again The Marauder thought it
doesn't have to be prepared for because
if you can't defend your preparations
and your facilities the people who
aren't prepared which is the vast
majority will come and take your
supplies and your solar systems and all
that that's right but you know I'm just
mentioning a couple things we actually
track 50 of them and I'm not sure which
one is the worst but the one that right
now is sounding the most alarm bells for
us is h5n1avian flu because it mutated
last year it's not the same virus and
it's wrong to call it bird flu it's now
bird and mammal flu that virus is
mutating and spreading amongst mammal
populations minks sea lions lots of
different populations thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time